aegon landed at the mouth of the
blackwater river and raised a primitive
aegon fort in the disputed land between
harrens and argilac's kingdom so that
neither could decide whose problem he
was
adopting the customs of the seven
kingdoms aegon unfurled his own banner
with the red three-headed dragon
breathing fire upon a black field
visenya crowned him with a ruby studded
circlet of valerian steel
while reigners hailed him as the first
high king the continent had seen since
the dawn age
as his lords and the gathered locals
teared him aegon named his loyal friend
to a small council led by oris baratheon
whom he called my strong right hand
the title stuck and abbas became the
first hand of the king
but for now aegon's kingdom contained
only a rocky island and a handful of
fields
the other kings had larger armies ships
castles and thousands of years of rule
but aegon had dragons
he had chosen for the words of his house
fire and blood
before he was done
the rivers fields and skies would turn
red
soon after his coronation
aegon returned to the mouth of the
blackwater river where he had first set
foot on westeros
a small town had since sprouted around
his primitive fort
to honor their new master the locals
dubbed it king's landing
though it looked more fit for a hedge
night with wooden palisades muddy
streets
and piles of mangled swords carted in
from every corner of the conquest
but when aegon made it his court
wood became stone
black mud was buried beneath a red keep
and the collected swords of aegon's foes
were blasted by dragon fire and became a
seat fit for the conqueror and the
greatest dynasty this world has ever
known
house targaryen
king's landing is both a city and a
curse
aegon the conqueror was the first king
to land there
his first conquest a tiny village at the
mouth of the blackwater river where he
raised a wooden fort
when it became clear that aegon would
earn his title
people flocked to the fort and renamed
it king's landing in his honor
the ploy succeeded
and aegon chose king's landing for his
capital over older and more beautiful
cities like
old town and
anywhere else
the carrying of royal favor thus became
the foundation of the city and blood its
bricks
maegor the cruel aegon's son completed
the city's famous red keep to hold the
trappings of power the royal family the
king's guard and the iron throne
to maintain the new castle secrets
maegor murdered all its masons and
craftsmen at a feast
which he catered with the new castle
servants
who soon found all its secrets for
themselves when the faith militant
challenged his rule maegor raised their
sect of remembrance to the ground with
them inside at prayer and erected the
dragon pit on the ashes
prince magor a warrior who was proud and
arrogant
maeger agreed to marry the high septon's
niece to unite the faith and the crown
but then secretly weared a second wife
in a valerian ceremony artfully
combining bigamy and heresy
one word of it got out the king was
forced to exile maegor and choose a
septon as his new hand
but the damage had been done
the king had trusted in family and his
brother had set off a rebellion that
would claim his rule and his life
his daughter to his son
the faith could brook such abomination
no longer
the high septon led the denunciation of
the targaryens and all over westeros the
faith militant took up their swords
against the dynasty and its supporters
the faith militant set upon and punished
the septon who had performed the
ceremony a few of the faith militants
more
militant members even scaled the walls
of the castle and would have slain the
king and his family had a night of the
king's guard not intervened
frightened the king fled to dragonstone
where he soon died of cramps
and so ascended the king's younger
brother
maegor the cruel
his first act was to challenge the faith
militant to kill him if they believed
his rule to be ungodly
to the order's eternal credit they
accepted
sir damon morrigan proposed a trial by
seven
said damon and six of the faith militant
against the king and his six champions
it was a contest in which the kingdom
itself was at stake and the accounts and
tales are many
but at the end of it
maegor alone lived
proving that the throne was rightfully
his
he mounted the black dragon valerian and
burnt down the sept in king's landing
while the faith militant were inside at
morning prayers
the screams of the burning and dying men
were said to echo throughout the city
omega had won the trial by seven he
demanded the complete destruction of the
faith militant and the faith itself if
necessary he made war upon the order
wherever he found it
yet the faith militant would not
surrender
raising armies of their own and turning
mega's own lords against him the
father's justice
may not always be swift
but it is certain one morning mega was
found dead on the iron throne
no one knows how
maego's cruelty died with him his
successor saw the wisdom of a united
crown and faith
and his hand reached an accord with the
high septon
as long as the iron throne defended the
faith
the faith would put aside its own swords
and its condemnation of the targaryens
the dance of the dragons
a stupid name for a targaryen civil war
where my ancestors danced away my
birthright
before the war house targaryen counted
18 dragons by the end we had two and
nearly as few targaryens
we would never be as powerful or as
feared again the dance began as many
dancers do with an old man and a young
girl the queen had failed to produce a
son for her king so he anointed his
daughter the princess rhaenyra as his
heir but years later the king remarried
and his new wife queen alicent of house
hightower gave him a son
feeble and foolish the old king refused
to change the succession he didn't even
see how his court had split into two
rival camps of blacks and greens after
the dresses of the princess and the
queen had worn to some tawny
[Music]
one night a servant found the old king
had died in his sleep and ran to inform
queen alicent protocol dictated that the
bells would be rung and a raven sent to
dragonstone to summon the air princess
rhaenyra for her coronation
but alison had other plans
none were more surprised to hear of
prince aegon's succession than prince
aegon himself
at first the fool rejected the crown but
his mother pointed out that his sister
rhaenyra would return such loyalty by
taking his head
as the old king's trueborn son he'd
always be a threat
aegon relented he was crowned in the
dragon pit and his wife and sister
helena became queen his brother eamonn
flew off to win over the few great lords
who support aegon didn't already have
the banner of the gold dragon flew over
king's landing and the red key as aegon
second of his name ascended the iron
throne
he would not sit it long
one day king's landing looked up and saw
two dragons circling their foul city
damon and rhaenyra had come for her
throne for the city was defenseless
eamonn had taken the king's army from
the city and worse he'd taken his dragon
vaga
seeing that resistance was hopeless the
small council surrendered the city the
queen mother alicent and the broken
queen helena
but not king aegon
somehow despite his wounds and delirium
he had vanished from the city
and so queen rhaenyra climbed the steps
and seated herself on the iron throne
legend has it that as she left the hall
later blood trickled down her legs and
hens proving the iron throne had spurned
her
nonsense
it's a chair made of steel blades
rhaenyra had wanted it all her life and
had sacrificed two sons for it
she likely gripped the damn thing too
tight
when raniere's last son wed aegon's only
daughter the dance of dragons officially
ended
passion burned men
all that was left of the riverlands
two scared children spouting oaths they
didn't understand
all that was left of the mighty house
targaryen
ancient skulls and hatchlings
that grew no bigger than cats
all that was left of the dragons
to steward his monument to vanity
baal has summoned the high septon of the
faith from his ancient seat in old town
and gifted him with ornate robes and a
crown of crystal and gold
and like a fool
the high septon put on his lord's motley
and danced at his lord's table
and with each passing year
the high septons fell ever lower
how can the flock be kept safe from
wolves
when the shepherd sleeps in their den
baylor himself appointed a simple-minded
stonemason believing him the smith
reborn
and when he died
baler replaced him with an
eight-year-old boy whom baylor had seen
speaking with dubs that answered with
the voices of the seven
still the common people revere balor as
the blessed
they tell of how he forced a high lord
to wash a beggar's feet
fasted to tame his unnatural lusts
and walked the boneway himself to make
peace with dawn
many septons and scepters even claim
that baylor rescued his cousin the
dragon knight from a snake pit
because no viper would strike a man so
pure and holy
a lie
baylor was bitten a dozen times and was
bedridden for half a year
and yet he didn't die
when the last dragon died
it was only a matter of time before the
targaryens followed
by only you mean another century which
they wasted trying to replace their last
advantage
incinerating their own palaces to hatch
dragon eggs drinking wildfire to become
dragons and let's not forget the mad
king's favorite burning man alive
so he could pretend to be a dragon
king slayer a word every man and woman
in westeros spits at me though many
can't even name the king i slayed
i understand
to them i'm a symbol of everything
they'll never have and a warning that'll
never apply
so they can loathe me from the safety of
their small lives
but when a dog goes mad we put it down
why not a king
serve the king's pleasure
as he burned richard stark alive and
strangled his son inciting the rebellion
i defended the king's honor against
corgis as his generals lost battle after
battle with robert
i kept the king's secrets when his
pyromancers in caches of wildfire
beneath king's landing
i gave the king council and my father's
army was at the city gate and grand
maester pycelle lied that my father had
come to save him
many forget that i also tried to defend
the king from heart when the lannister
soldiers poured through the gates it
fell to me to hold the red keeper as the
only king's god in the city
i knew we were lost and sent to ares
asking his sleeve to make terms
my man came back with a royal command
bring me your father's head if you are
no traitor
aries would have no yielding his
pyromancer was with him my messenger
said
i knew what that meant
aries targaryen was alone in his throne
room when i found him picking at his
scapt and bleeding hands
the fool was always cutting himself in
the iron throne
burn them burn them he kept muttering
ares had decided to let robert be king
after all over the charred bones and
ashes of king's landing he must have
thought his pyromancer was near enough
to obey him but i'd killed him a few
minutes before in the courtyard as i
approached the throne
sanity flashed behind the king's eyes
for a moment just long enough to read
the look in mine his eyes grew huge and
the royal mouth drooped open in shock he
turned and ran
a single thrust was all it took to end
the greatest dynasty the world had ever
seen
beneath the empty eyes of the dead
dragons on the walls the last dragon
kings wheeled like a pig and shat
himself
so easy i thought
a king should die harder than this
you